support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com / people ready
I'm Tom Steinberg and i'm the managing
General Partner of the Highland consumer
fund
President Obama inherited a incredibly
challenging situation so that he was not
Delta an easy hand I think and the jury
in many ways is still out as to what
they're doing on the positive side i
think president obama is instilling a
degree of confidence on the part of the
American consumer as well as a part of
foreign foreigners looking in America
what America stands for I think he's
creating a far more positive atmosphere
my relatives in Europe for just really
down the United States now feel much
better about us in our products and they
did a year ago so that's a positive my
concerns are that is leaving lots of
things in the hands of a Democratic
Congress and in some cases particularly
motivated by their large contributors
from the trial lawyers and the unions
they're going to do a lot of things that
are really dumb whether they're rini
creating crazy tax structures that
eliminate the desire for entrepreneurs
to go take the risk we'd like to see
them take you to create the next Apple
or the next Intel or the next staples
whether it's this union card sign-up
nonsense which is disgraceful the notion
that you can have a secret election
decide on whether a workforce needs a
union or not that you can someone take
some guys to bargain a sign a card and
end up with a union where the government
that arbitrates a contract this is just
insane and so I worry a great deal about
that that in the process of building a
nation where to build France inside of
the United States
well I think there's a totally different
environment on executive comp I've been
fortunate to be involved in companies
that are generally speaking extremely
entrepreneurial don't give a whole lot
of perks in some cases virtually no
perks it's funny in the petsmart that
this the tables disclosing all your
benefits and we just we've loved
listening because we would do not offer
do not offer do not offer do not offer
country clubs no executive jet time no
etc so we like it the but the same time
you've now got restrictions on the
ability to offer equity because the
formula formulae that people throw out
you don't build into the fact that
you're not doing a lot of other things
and you'd like to compensate by giving
greater stock awards and you're
constrained by what the dilution
percentage is versus your peer group and
all kinds of other metrics some of which
are good and some which are just not
appropriate and it's been secondarily
it's a think about trying at the end of
2008 set saying the bonus targets for
your chief executive officer of 2009 how
do you do it what economic assumptions
do you make and how can you possibly be
fair and if you've assumed a doomsday
scenario and having forbid things turn
out all right you pay 300 sent bonuses
are going to criticize if you set
aggressive goals and the economy remains
lousy or gets even worse you'll probably
have the third year in a row when
nobody's earned a bonus near you and you
could lose employees how do you deal
with that it's incredibly hard
I don't think government does many
things well but one thing I think that
the Obama administration did very very
well is the phrase they used of stress
test it's kind of like when you go for
your checkup and they check out your
heart they put you in a treadmill and
get you going for a while and raise your
heart rate and see how your heart
responds well what each of the companies
we've been talking about has done is run
through very negative scenarios in terms
of stress tests negative in terms of
revenues negative in terms of gross
margin pressures instead of themselves
can I survive that scenario and once
they're subject themselves to that
stress test and then though they can get
through that then they know that they're
at least going to survive and as soon as
things stabilize they can then pounce
by regulating hedge funds or at least
getting transparency is a good thing I'm
not a Wall Street expert but I think of
any question that some of what was going
on on Wall Street was simply market
manipulation by large hedge funds and I
think you know we need to have rid of
transparency into that and hedge funds
are yet it's a broad brush to describe
some great people or fundamental stock
pickers and long term holders to submit
some real people in the fast money
business so who you know week a lot of
havoc in it so i think that greater
transparency actually is in regulation
that is a smart thing and a good thing
what I worry about along with that is
we're going to get into over-regulation
and craziness so the notion that the
government isn't until the Northern
Trust Company that they can't entertain
their clients at a golf tournament to me
is ridiculous or the notion that a bank
like Wells Fargo can't take its highest
performers to Las Vegas for a weekend
without being tarred and feathered in
the wall street journal in the USA today
it's just flat out wrong
the biggest obstacle I've probably had
to overcome of my business career is one
the federal government through at me at
staples we back in the late 90s agreed
to acquire our largest competitor office
depot they're actually bigger than we
were at the time and first there would
acquire us they rent a hard times end up
acquiring them and the deal made a lot
of sense in retrospect if one had to
rewrite history all the things we said
to the Federal Trade Commission what
would happen in fact it happened the
internet level prices walmart became a
huge competitor but the time they didn't
see those things and we lost and monday
we heard the federal trade commission
that they are going to get a junction
against our merging and we've got a
court but it'd be months and months tour
if not years to overcome that and the
merger by office depot's desired diet
died and there were lots of lots of
entation to say oh if only and coulda
woulda shoulda etc and i resolved in the
week prior to that that no matter what
happened i wrote two speeches what is
what everything goes well and the second
was what if it doesn't happen and that
day it didn't happen I went out there
people's okay folks this is over we'd
always done old co and new co plans
meaning o'cl meaning if we couldn't do
the merger old coal plans are in let's
move forward and I don't want to hear a
word about the failed merger ever its
grounds for termination we're not going
to look backward and look forward and in
fact out of that time period staples
took on a huge spread of growth in fact
a couple years later past office depot
on revenues and now staples market
capitalization dwarfs that of office
team
support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft com / people ready